okay in one of the creepiest yet most
revealing twitter threads
ever to be posted on the platform i
think a teacher recently fretted out
loud
that virtual classes might allow parents
to hear him
brainwashing their kids and he's very
afraid of that matthew r k
an educator and author of a book called
uh
how to lead meaningful race
conversations in the classroom
worried that quote conservative parents
would be able to
interfere with the quote messy work of
indoctrinating children into critical
race theory gender theory
and other left-wing dogmas here's the
entire thread
which has since been set to private but
here's a screenshot of it
it says so this fall virtual class
discussions will have many potential
spectators
parents siblings etc in the same room
we'll never be quite sure who's
overhearing the discourse
what does this do for our equity slash
inclusion work how much have students
depended on the
somewhat secure barriers of our physical
classrooms to encourage vulnerability
how many of us have installed some
version of what happens here stays here
to help with this while conversations
about race are in my wheelhouse and
remain a concern in this no-walls
environment
i am most intrigued by the damage that
helicopter
snowplow parents can do in the in the
host conversations about gender
sexuality and while conservative parents
are my chief concern
i know that the damage can come from the
left too if we are engaged in the messy
work of destabilizing a kid's racism or
homophobia or transphobia
how much do we want their classmates
parents
piling on
that's what he had to say it's important
to note that
while some teachers responded to kaye's
comments with the appropriate level of
horror and disgust
many others chimed in to share their own
strategies for brainwashing during
during a pandemic apparently this is
something that the teachers have thought
about and
have come up with strategies for one
teacher said that uh she'd also been
quote thinking about the problem that
kaye described and
had decided that she'd ask her students
about their preferred
preferred pronouns via survey uh though
she still worries that uh quote
caregivers might see it
and learn something about their children
that they weren't supposed to know
apparently
another teacher said that students last
semester would sometimes
quote type secrets into the chat
whenever the discussion turned to quote
anti-racism and gender inclusive
another complained that a white parent
she made sure to specify
white in her district recorded a zoom
class
and then quote filed a complaint against
the teacher for anti-racist
for a r for an anti-racist aloud
saying the teacher's commentary was
inappropriate and biased
and this the teacher says is going to be
an issue
a 9th grade teacher shared shared in the
commiseration
saying that her class required students
to quote read and respond to a news
article this is part of her class
but that participation in this exercise
is stunted now because
quote outsiders are listening
the outsiders to be clear are the
children's parents
and another teacher with pronouns listed
in her twitter handle so you know what
she's up to
said that she plans to use the chat
function more than voice lectures
because she wants children to quote
share that information with her in a
quote parentless way
then a science teacher agreed with all
the sentiments expressed here
but summarized it bluntly saying parents
are dangerous
and these are just the comments that
were captured in screenshots
before the tweets were all made private
presumably there is
more where this came from a lot more
now i think several points
should be made here in response
first this may seem like a side issue
compared with the very large problems
unwittingly or maybe not so unwittingly
exposed by the thread but
it should be said that that classrooms
are certainly not
safe places for children to be
vulnerable
students may say and do things when
they're with their peers in school
that they wouldn't say and do at home
but only a fool who doesn't understand
the first thing about child psychology
and the effects of peer pressure would
assume that the child's
at school version of himself is the most
authentic
much less the most healthy the the
pressure to conform to the values and
opinions of your peers in the classroom
is immense and overwhelming
and often suffocating for these kids
there's a reason why rejection and
alienation by peers has contributed to a
true epidemic of suicide
among young people suicide is
skyrocketing among young people and in
fact
the very same people who extol the
classroom as a safe place for
vulnerability
will also tell us on different days and
in different contexts
that bullying is a major problem at
school for today's youth
and many of them are driven to
self-destruction because of it so
which is it is the classroom a place for
open and genuine dialogue where children
can safely express their truest
feelings and beliefs or is it a place
rife with bullying and mockery where
rigid conformity is demanded
and those who fail to meet the demands
are severely punished
it certainly can't be both of those
things and the answer is that is
it's much more the latter than the
former
second point an adult
keeping a secret with a child
and helping the child conceal that
secret from his parent
especially when the secret has anything
to do with sexuality
is acting in a way that is nothing short
of predatory now if you heard a strange
man
on the playground whisper to your child
this will just be
our little secret okay don't tell your
mom and dad you would assume that the
man is some kind of sex offender and
respond accordingly
does this behavior suddenly transform
from disturbing to admirable if the
strange man is a teacher
no it doesn't but this is a sort of
license that society has given to
teachers
on the theory that they cannot do the
work of educating unless they have more
power over
and intimate knowledge of their students
than the students own parents do
which brings us finally to to point
three which is that
a public school teacher is not supposed
to be
and should not try to be educator
parent shaman spiritual guide therapist
friend
confidant and sex counselor all rolled
into one
he is meant to fill only the first role
of educator
and and only in the subject that he's
been assigned to teach so it's very
limited
a child's actual parents can only become
to be viewed as
dangerous and intrusive and outsiders
when teachers begin to view themselves
in the school system as the true
guardians and and conservators of the
children that are temporarily in their
care
and that ultimately is the problem with
the modern education system
children are not old enough to be
emancipated
they can't go out and and live their own
lives
they can't make every decision for
themselves or even most decisions for
themselves
they must belong to someone
not to say owned like objects but cared
for
and protected like the vulnerable and
relatively helpless human beings they
are
the fundamental question is who do they
belong to
different cultures in different times
and places have had different answers to
that question
here in contemporary american society
there are generally two ways of looking
at it
children belong to their parents
or they belong to the school system
which is to say the government
in one vision a child is a son or
daughter in the other
the child is a ward of the state only
one of these visions is healthy natural
and humanizing only one can properly
facilitate
a child's emotional mental intellectual
and spiritual growth
the school system doesn't just have a
wrong and harmful idea of what
education is it has a wrong and harmful
idea of what a
child is and what its fundamental role
in a child's life is supposed to be
[Music]
and that is why i will not be sending my
kids
into the education systems clutches and
neither should you hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated